[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb Ryan is shuffling
papers and trying to get his [__]
together Ryan is your [__] together
today I just I shed my I I I [__] my
hair ends up everywhere oh great it's
all over my couch it's all over the
couch it's all over my apartment it's
all over the floor just my head hair oh
good and so it it just sort of ended up
on a piece of paper and I was trying to
brush it away and that's how we started
well it's good to have you here shedar
thank you Mr shedar that's me uh thanks
for listening thanks for making this
podcast your choice uh if you're here
for Jenifer love huitt and you're only
here for Jennifer Love hu I I just hope
you like the podcast and afterwards if
you like it enough maybe you want to
hear other interviews and follow us at
um inside of you podcast inside of you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook inside
you pod on the Twitter you can watch the
show on YouTube and um I'd really
appreciate if you wrote a review or just
uh continue listening and give the
podast podcast a chance shout out to all
the top tier patrons actually shout out
to all the patrons whether you uh give a
little or a lot uh you mean a lot to
this podcast and uh I really really
appreciate you happy holidays you can go
to patreon P
n.com inside of you inside patreon.com
inside and uh become a patron member a
patron become a patron um I'll send you
a message when you join and top tiers
get things like boxes from me every
couple months and notes and there's all
sorts of store discounts and there's uh
there's there's a ton just go look at it
look at the tiers and all that stuff and
uh really appreciate your support I need
it without uh Patron I couldn't do this
podcast there's just no doubt about it
am I right Ryan yes yes very true Ryan
knows the truth um if you want to check
out the store um that's in that's inside
of you online store and we've got so
many good so much good stuff there uh
Lexus scripts and ship keys from
Smallville and t-shirts and uh a lot of
stuff and if you join top tier patrons
the the prize box is going to be pretty
cool this next time around because I got
a lot of new things where's your little
light you I put it in on my keys put it
it's it's a keychain with a light it
says inside you and it glows and it's
really cool yeah but there's other stuff
too that you get not just that anyway um
I'm on the Cameo you can go to link tree
for everything on my Instagram atth
Michel Rosen bomb go to link tree and
you can see uh cons that I'm doing you
can see my live
podcast my live podcast is downtown at
the region theater it is January 24th
special guest Kristen Ritter Jessica
Jones um she's done breaking bad she has
done so much great stuff and if you want
to meet her there's a meet and greet for
VIPs and it's so much fun if you didn't
join us with Zack Levi you really missed
out we had a blast it was was a great
time tons of laughter some intense
conversations and some really funny
conversations so uh get tickets on my
link tree at the Michel Rosen bomb on
Instagram and uh thank you for all your
love and support this year Our Guest
this uh week is Jennifer Love hwit
second time around but it's been a while
it's been a while and uh I love talking
to her I think she's one of the sweetest
human beings on the planet she truly has
a heart of gold gives so much and um is
a solid person and so talented and we
talk about her show 911 we talk about uh
we talk about everything you're going to
really enjoy this so without further Ado
Ryan are you ready for this I'm ready
let's get inside of Jennifer Love HT
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you with Michael Rose and B
[Music]
inside of you with Michael rosenbom was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you know I don't get to see you
very often I know primarily because
you're married you have a big career and
you have three children now a two a nine
and a seven and an eight an eight yeah
that's a lot of work man so much work I
mean do you have a
Nanny um we have had help like off and
on we don't have any yeah I mean yes but
not like a you know like some people
have them that have been there since
like the babies were born and stuff like
that we haven't had that um we waited a
really long time to do that because I
think we just wanted to be super
involved and you know kind of get in
there but um but yeah it's definitely
getting hard not to have help yeah
because I remember like you were like
all about that's my puppy but you were
all about like family even from your
first kid I remember you were doing I
think the Ghost Whisper or Criminal
Minds or something and you said I'm
taking a three-year Hiatus yeah you just
said boom I'm done family yeah was that
a hard decision or was that something
that you were pretty adamant about off
the Go I mean it was if I mean honest it
was hard because other people didn't
like it it was easy for me um but it was
hard for people around me I think they
all were like oh is this postpartum as
she lost her mind what's what's a
combination of both what's going on um
and I was just very clear but you know I
had my daughter a year after my mom
passed yeah so I was very much like oh
the universe is just you know I consider
myself a student of the universe daily
and it had just taught me a very
valuable lesson and that there are
bigger things in life than you know
being on the train of Hollywood and I
needed to just I I just needed to be
well I needed to like take care of
myself mentally and emotionally and
being being a mom for me did that and
being an actress at that time didn't so
I just needed a break yeah I remember
that we've talked about that many moons
ago when I had you on and by the way you
know we'll get into the whole Hollywood
train because I know you want to talk
about that and all that stuff but I'm
looking at your Instagrams and I just
want to know I look this might not air
till after Halloween or whatever but
folks if you look at Jenifer love hwi's
Instagram page you're going to see a lot
of Halloween during Halloween and this
is like this isn't like me I go to CVS
and I grab a $4.99 plastic pumpkin and
put it in front of my house this is like
detail it's all I think you're a person
that's always in the detail if you throw
someone's birthday party it's detailed
if you ever Halloween detailed the
Christmas tree everything's got to be
right and you want and especially for
your kids you want them to just see it
be it live it I do it's expensive how
much do you spend don't lie on Halloween
oh I don't even want to talk about it
and I don't know that I even look um I
um I had to get a store room unit let me
just say that much for all my holiday
decorations um I am actually like
officially starting a brand called the
holiday junkie and it's going to be like
all of my holiday stuff because I'm
obsessed but part of the reason that I'm
obsessed with Halloween is it's Brian's
birthday so for us it's like this big
holiday but it's also his day which I
think is so cool so we really go over
the top his birthday is on the 31st on
the 31st wow and how old will he be how
old will Brian be he's gonna be
45 and I won't ask your age I'm gonna be
45 in February oh so you're young but
he's older than me so boom well you look
great you look young you look I still
would think you like in your
mid-30s that's really nice but we we you
know so Halloween you spend a a lot of
money and now you're starting your own
product line what is it called again
Hollywood Holiday junkie Hollywood
junkie holiday junkie holiday junkie
what will you sell holiday things yeah
so your own design I've been writing
cards with um this company called 2021
Co we have a whole like holiday line of
cards um I have uh two big things coming
out next year that have to do with the
holiday junk that I can't tell you about
yet but I'll come back on maybe if
you'll have me yes um and and yeah and
then we're going to do like products and
stuff it's going to be really fun I'm
excited it could be pretty lucrative too
huh I mean I think so it's just like
it's my happy place so I just need it in
my life to like you know give some
balance well you kind of do not you kind
of do you do everything like actress
singer book was in the bestselling New
York Times bestseller list you're doing
products you're doing it's just like and
I've started doing that too but I I do
it and I I think you do it like for this
as well for this reason is is I do
things like I'm coming out with a a
children's book and I always wanted to
make one and Simon and Shuster putting
it out in June and it's really I might
have to ask you for a quote on the back
congratulations yes it's and it's just
like look is it a money maker no but I
wanted to do it I've always wanted to do
it so I'm doing things I'm coming out
with a pet product I'm like you know and
it's just called you know Rosy something
I can't tell you exactly what it is yet
but um and I just I was working with my
friend I'm like let's just do this this
will be fun if it it's not a big risk if
it doesn't work oh oh well so yeah I
like I started it took me a long time
but I always was chasing things that
chasing after things that people wanted
me to do you have to act you have to do
this what are you doing wasting your
time what and I'm like so I was doing
things based really on what other people
wanted my agent my business manager or
even some friends and then I thought is
it what you want to do what do you want
to do well I want to make music I'm not
the best singer in the world but I can
sing and I can write songs and I want to
do it for me I don't want to be a rock
star or make millions and it'd be nice
but I'm doing it for me do you find that
the older you get you start to do more
of that yes and it's beautiful but isn't
it frustrating that we wait so long yeah
I have this conversation with my kids
all the time eight and 10 and I'm
already like guys spend your life doing
things you really want to do
like spend your life doing that
because you're happy when you're doing
things that you really want to do and I
get it like Hollywood is this very
specific pocket of time and by the way
people that said to me hey you know what
let's not go to college right now like
you really want to go I really wanted to
go to college and they were like you
could go to college and you would have
an amazing time but you're also like on
this trajectory right now like just keep
it going keep the train moving because
it's Hollywood you never know when it's
gonna you know yeah and they weren't
wrong about that and I had a great time
um but there's still a part of me that
wishes I'd gone to college you know what
I mean and like why am I now at 45
wanting to do that you know wait you
want to go back to college now I don't
know there's a part of me that would
really love to why don't you do a
semester well maybe I'll wait until my
daughter goes to college and that way it
can be like in the bushes watching
everything that's is that creepy that
reminded me of Napoleon Dynamo when she
knocks on the door and she's like I'm
saving up to sell these bands for
college and Kips in the other room and
goes your mom goes to
college always cracked me
up inside of you is brought to you by
Aura frames hang on if you guys want the
best Christmas gift they sent me one of
these Aura frames and it is beautiful
where is it Ryan when you walk in oh
yeah it's right in your living room
right next to the fireplace are you in
there I am in there you are in there
it's so good here's the thing with
pictures you know it's a digital frame
right digital picture frame from Aura
frames and it's the nice
it comes like a gift so you could send
it to somebody and it opens you open it
it's like it looks like it was a it's a
gift it's almost wrapped you know um
what's great about this is I have
millions of pictures on my computer that
I never look at I forget about once I
upload them I'm done with these Aura
frames the digital
frames you have I have hundreds of
pictures that are continuously going and
I'm reminded of all the joy and
happiness I have in my life and the
memories of my friends and these times
and it's right there in the living room
so all can see when I'm sitting there
with the dogs I look over I see it and
it's just wonderful the holidays are all
about connecting with loved ones and
there's no better way to do that than
with a digital picture frame from Aura
frames wire cutter called it the best
digital photo frame and it's easy to see
why you can upload your favorite picks
of the family to one frame and relive
all those happy moments again and if
that's not personal enough you can even
upload a video message to play on the
frame as soon as they plug it in so the
first thing they hear is your voice and
how much you love them how cool is that
give the best gift ever this holiday
season and honestly it is the best gift
there's nothing else I could think of
that really just sort of accentuates
your love for someone and also you know
it's it's just a warm loving gift and it
the gift that keeps on giving I'm going
to get my grandmother one I'm going to
get my mother one
I don't know how many pictures I have of
my mother but regardless she'll have
pictures of my dogs and things like that
visit Aura frames.com today and get $30
off their bestselling frames with the
code inside these frames sell out
quickly though so get yours before
they're gone that's AA frames a a
frames.com with the promo code inside
visit Ora frames.com for terms and
conditions um you know you sent me first
of all let me talk about your tattoo
what does your tattoo say oh my gosh I
have a lot of tattoos which one but the
new one the new one it says the universe
always
provides it does it does when you think
about it when you channel that when
you're open to it when you're open to it
and you give it all your faith I believe
that the trick about it which has taken
me a long time to learn is that it
doesn't always provide when you want it
to and in the way that you want it to
but if you really look deep at your life
and the situations that you're in
whether it's when you're in them or
later you will realize that the Universe
always provides it does and I think you
have to I talk about this ad nauseum but
no matter what job you're doing out
there you know have a passion you don't
have to make money off it you don't have
to but if you're doing something on the
side you love that will give you the
energy to do the things you don't love
and it will make you feel like you you
know you're you're doing something for
yourself so whatever that is if you've
always had a desire to build cars or
whatever or paint or you know work with
uh children or work with you know at
nursing homes whatever it is you know
some of these things give you
purpose yeah and and I think it's just
so important and a lot of times look
it's taken me I'm 51 now and I'm just
like why is it taking me so long but
maybe that's just the that just my fate
it was just like hey it's better to find
it now than not finding it and going why
did I ever why didn't I ever do anything
that I wanted to do you know what I mean
but also the key I feel like is like I
have I have friends who are like I don't
know I've been trying to Manifest this
thing and it's not happening or I've
I've I don't know I I wake up and I say
this is what I want you know every day
and I'm like well question a is are you
grateful like are you practicing
gratitude while you're prac iing
manifestation because the universe will
reward a grateful person all day but a
non-g grateful person they're like I
have so many people that are manifesting
I have no time for you like I have to I
have to move up what do you say what are
your gratitudes and you do you say them
every night or every
morning so I've been doing this thing I
was going to tell you today I've been
doing this thing for 21 days now where I
found like 15 affirmations that I
absolutely love and I say 15 of them
every morning um and then I say three
very specific ones at night and I have
been really like no matter what even if
the baby's kept me all night and I'm
exhausted or someone I love is going
through something that's like really
dark and crazy um or the world that we
live in which is insane at the moment um
and has been for you know the last like
three and a half years in so many
different ways um I start with gratitude
and I end with gratitude and I really
feel
like I really feel like it's just it's
just changed me like in such a really
profound cool way and so I highly
recommend it for people like just just
start and and gratitude is different for
everyone sometimes it's my family
sometimes it's just being grateful that
I can get up and move my body in the
morning um it's I always say that I'm
grateful that I get the to live another
day because I really do feel that way um
and then at night I just kind of like
than the world around me for the
opportunity to like all the things that
I learned and took in um and I released
any like negative or icky stuff and then
I I asked for like a peaceful rest and I
get it and no matter how no matter how
tired you are you always do that I do do
you say it out loud I do say it out loud
you know what my kids have started
joining me on the nighttime ones and
they love it like last night attakus or
night before night night before attakus
was like can I can I say your
affirmations with you will you say them
out loud for me too and I was like yeah
and so sometimes we'll do ones in the
morning for them before they go to
school but they really like the idea of
feeling like oh we can we can have a
little bit of control over like goodness
and stuff that goes into our minds
that's beautiful get it embedded in them
at a young age gratefulness because I
don't think I knew anything about that I
mean I just either my childhood was a
whirlwind so it was dysfunction and all
this stuff around so there was no time
for you know thankfulness and and I
didn't understand that or learn it uh I
just I was just living in chaos and and
and that development age you know
whether it's four to n or whatever that
little Gap is that's when we really
learn and yeah and we remember
everything from around that time and
like if they were bad we don't forget
them and if they were good we don't
forget them so it's incorporating a lot
of love and and a good feeling and
confidence and things for your kids and
I'm not a dad but you know if I ever had
a kid I I definitely would instill that
that love and that gratefulness and and
and those things so I I commend you on
that I think that's pretty bad thank and
it sounds like you learned it from your
mom I did I did she was a very grateful
person very grateful um yeah yeah and I
think in losing her I learned it like
tfold um which has been a gift so she
gave it to me twice she gave it to me
once while she was here and once while
she was gone you know you know I can I
read this little post that you sent on
Instagram it was to your mom and it said
11 years ago my life changed in a moment
we didn't get to say goodbye but I think
it's because we wouldn't have known how
I see you in my kids every day I feel
you in things I say and smile because
I'm more like you than I thought I honor
You by trying to create Magic for my
family just like you did for us I love
you deeply I'm so grateful you are a mom
this day will always hurt because you
were that special always and forever mom
and it it brought me to tears it was
just like cuz I I
remember what a tough time you were
going through it was just an absolute
shock and it's always a shock but for
you it was even more of a shot do you um
do you still uh think about her all the
time do you still get emotional about
her yeah yeah I do I um I do I do think
about her all the time it's it's
interesting in
like
um
so I I have I wasn't actually gonna say
this today but I will say it I um I just
wrote a book another one yeah that will
be coming out um next year I haven't
told anybody this is this is this is me
telling people um telling you um and it
um it is it is a love letter to my mom
um about who she was who she was to me
all the things but I also talk about
losing her and how that sort of affect
Ed me in the early days of like having
my children and um you know all that
she's been left with all that she left
me with um and so in writing the book I
had to like really go into some like sad
stuff um and some uncomfortable places
and um and I was just telling my kids
the other day they were like you
seem um lighter about Mimi which is what
they call her and I was like you know
what I I feel that way and it's like
something
about writing my love for her like made
me fall in love with her all over again
but in this like Joyful Way instead of
this deep sad way um and so I will
always I always have this like little
pocket that hurts um but it's lighter
than it used to be um 11 years later and
um and I think it's because I got to
like just really give my love to her in
this book and so I'm really excited for
people to read it it's about the
holidays it's about you know um being
joyful in your life and creating magic
and you know all those things there's
lots of light stuff in it too but it in
the beginning it's really just about her
um and and how she's in everything that
I do now for my kids and my husband and
my family um is to honor her in in like
a really beautiful way so I'm in a I'm
in a really good place with my my
grieving of her because um I feel like
especially in this last year writing the
book we've spent a lot of time
um and I've really felt her close and
it's been it's been really nice that is
that is awesome yeah I think you know
God forbid if my mom passed away it
would probably be
a three pages three pages of no I'm just
kidding but like uh no I don't want her
you know she's she's uh you know the
thing is you know she always guilted me
when I was young like you only have one
mother so I I thought no matter how bad
it is I only have one which is a
complete manipulation it's like you know
but what are the things if you had to
sum it up like what are the things that
have made you a better person that she
um gave
you what things did she give you deep
gratitude for sure um I I remember when
we first came to La my mom was like okay
there's there's you know two things that
I want you to think about like being a
kid in in Hollywood she was like one is
the second it's not fun we pack up our
stuff and we go home that's it it has to
be fun because you're a kid and you
should be having fun and so if this
isn't fun then we have to we like forget
it yeah I was like okay then the second
thing is she said I want you to look at
your career as like that toy that you
want from Santa so bad when you're a kid
and then you get it and there's two
types of kids one will take the toy and
break it the first day and smash it into
pieces even though it was the thing that
they wanted more than anything in the
world or you have the kid who like packs
up their room when they're getting ready
to go to college and that toy is still
in a box somewhere because they took
such good care of it right that they
loved it forever and she was like you
can look at your career and you can take
care of it either way that you want and
she's like but I really hope that you'll
choose the kid who is something really
proud to still hold on to like years and
years and years and years later that is
great I never forgot that she said it
and so that's what I did like that's how
I always treated my career I was like
okay and I would always like even in my
20s I would be like am I trying to smash
this right now like that kid at
Christmas you know what I mean I'm like
or do I want to hold on to it I was like
okay let's be let's be calm let's be
kind let's be you know grateful to have
it and you know all of those things so
those two things definitely stick out um
my mom also was just I don't even know
how to explain it but like literally
everyone that met her felt like they had
known her forever and they loved her
like she could just walk into a room
and people thought even even though she
was special to us and like maybe not
into the rest of the world people
thought she was someone like that's how
she carried herself she carried herself
with this like presence
of light and it was amazing when she
passed I got all these random messages
from people and like DMS from people and
I knew that they were real because they
were like I felt like I knew your mom
forever and I felt like I was a better
person after I met her and I was like oh
that person actually did meet my mom cuz
that's just who she was wow so it was
great and so I try to have that energy
you know how lucky how lucky it is to
grow up with someone with your mom being
a role model like my grandfather was a
role model for me yeah um but to have
your one of your parents as the role
model and someone you aspired to you
know to do good things because of and
and you probably make a lot of decisions
based on you know how would mom feel
about this do you do that oh yeah oh
yeah definitely definitely in good and
bad ways you know I don't want to make
it sound like my mom and I were perfect
all the time or like she didn't ever get
on my nerves or we never had you know
fights about things or or whatever but I
I was always very conscious of the fact
that like people would always say be
careful one day you're G to turn around
and turn out like your mother and I was
my reaction was always like thank you
yeah good I really hope so you know and
um but yeah I definitely I definitely
think of things all the time like with
my kids I'll be you know or I laugh at
like oh my gosh if my mom was here right
now she would be laughing at me in this
situation or how I'm gonna handle this
or like what's gonna happen and um yeah
she was just she was just tremendous and
um and I really feel so lucky to have
had her and I think in writing the book
now I live more with her memory in that
space than I do in like the everyday
sadness space obviously on the big
anniversaries and things like that
Christmas is really hard for me I always
miss start Christmas the most um and I
you know I'll always have those because
like I said she deserves it she deserves
me to be that sad about her because she
was that special um but yeah I've been
I've been living more in just Joy about
her lately that's great that's been
really nice and the fact that your kids
see it is just like memorizing all right
Switching gears here a little bit you
you text me this yeah and we don't have
to go into it but I think it was pretty
important to you you said a lot of stuff
to say about
aging in in Hollywood they freeze us at
the age they feel we were our best like
we aren't allowed to grow past that and
that was very that that was very
profound and it and I wanted you to just
talk about that a little because I know
that it was important to
you yeah it's such an interesting so I
actually it was actually Taylor Swift
that said that I'm I'm a Swifty um wait
Taylor Swift said what I just said not
not that exactly but she was talking
about the idea that like people freeze
you like they they have this moment when
they fall in love with you right as a as
an artist or a creative or a celebrity
or whatever it is that you're seeing as
to people and they they pick this moment
and then that's who they want you to
always be um and there's something
really beautiful about that but there's
also something really not okay about
that in
that it it's interesting I don't want to
say that aging is hard because aging is
a privilege it means you're here it
means you're still living it it means
your every line is because of a smile or
a laugh you had or in my case too many
crying scenes which have given me like
this like I'm just always crying on on
camera I things what but I earn those
right like every crime scene I earn
those um and so it's beautiful but Aging
in Hollywood is really hard it's really
hard
because you can't do anything right you
know I had this thing like a few weeks
ago and this is what made me text you
about it I had uh I was getting my hair
done and I had not a stitch of makeup on
so I threw on a filter and it was just a
filter that like at the time looked nice
in the light at the salon I really gave
it no thought and I put it on and the
picture ended up somewhere and a bunch
of people were like Jennifer Love hu is
unrecognizable this show is sponsored by
better help better help online therapy
do not fast forward because this is
something that truly helps so many
people around the world so many of my
friends um you hear the guests how many
guests talk about therapy and it's just
it's amazing and a lot of people I talk
about how you know a family member who
you know no one will understand me no
one knows what I've been through well
that's not true there's so many people
that do know what you're going through
and and um they've seen it all and
therapy really truly helps it helps me
and whether or not your family gives
gifts during the holidays you can always
give yourself the gift of a healthier
you whether by starting therapy going
easier on yourself in tough moments or
treating yourself to a day of complete
rest remember to give yourself some love
this holiday season this time of year
can be a lot it's hectic it's stressful
it's really easy to forget to take time
for yourself but you deserve it as much
as your loved ones do and it's super
convenient with better help it's
entirely online and designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule even during the holidays just
fill out a brief questionnaire this
thing takes no time at all to get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge so if you're not
vibing with your therapist don't think
oh it's not working no just switch to
another therapist and feel the Vibes
feel good about who you're talking to
you feel uh comfortable and you will
find that with better help in the season
of giving give yourself what you need
with better help visit better help
help.com insid toay to get 10% off your
first month that's better help
hp.com inside inside of you is brought
to you by discover if you like using
debit over credit don't you think it's
time you also get rewarded well now you
can with discover cashback debit it's a
checking account that rewards everyone
with cash back on everyday purchase plus
there are no fees period we're talking
date nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends and it's
now earning you cash back with discover
cashback debit check out eligibility and
terms at discover.com
slashback debit Discover Bank member
FDIC hey guys I'm doing another live
podcast downtown LA at the Regent
Theater and my special guest for January
24th is Kristen Ritter breaking B
Jessica Jones this is going to be a
soldout event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles that's a regent inside of you
with Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited and then another place was like
she's unrecognizable and so she's gone
to filters because she doesn't want us
to know how how bad she actually looks
now in her 40s God and I was like this
is crazy right so then I did a bunch of
like overthe toop like crazy filters on
my Instagram and I was like all natural
no filter like trying to make fun of it
and then they came after me for that and
they were like well now she's just
defending herself and like why is she
defend and I realized I was like I can
do I can do no I can do no right and why
are you focusing so much in these
[__] who have nothing better to do
than to put you down because because to
pretend that we we don't is a lie I know
I know you're right we we're human and
yes they're known as haters and they're
known as people who like you're just
supposed to turn your comments off and
you're supposed to but it's human nature
to be like what do people think about me
I've been an actor for 36 years you know
this like you're the same way it's like
you don't want to care what people think
about you but you have to care what
people think about you you want to know
what's out there and I will say the
majority of people have been very kind
to me they've grown up with me they look
like I do now right we're all getting
lines and maybe in menopause and who
knows what else is coming for us you
know about to get a
colonoscopy whatever like we're all
there and it's beautiful and it's weird
and you know we're all doing it together
and it's fine but like there are those
people out there and the only reason
those people bother me is because I
think that it is I I'm a I'm a mother of
a
girl and it's dangerous what we put on
people it's dangerous I think to say to
women when you can't you can't look like
you're not 22 to me anymore because I
don't know how to I don't know how to
take that okay well that's your problem
because I'm 44 and I this is what I look
like you know what I mean um and so it
just it just bothered me in that way
that I feel like I just feel like we're
and and by the
way that whatever age it is I feel like
people maybe these people like have
picked they seem to have picked like
somewhere between 23 and 25 for me which
by the way she was like congratulations
to that 23 or 25 but I'm a different
person now yeah you know um and it's
great but there's also
like that 23 and 25 year old wasn't in
her body like at 23 24 25 I didn't feel
self-confident I felt watched I felt
like I had to be everything for
everybody all the time I was called sexy
before I ever knew what SE being sexy
was like I was 17 years old on the on
the cover of Maxim and I had no idea why
I was on the cover of Maxum I was I was
honored and I loved it but I was like
what you know I remember doing um
Heartbreakers at 23 and the director was
like we just need to be sexier and I had
to pull him aside and I was like I don't
know I don't know what that means I'm
only 23 I know that I'm supposed to be
this thing for people but I don't know
what that means and he had to like help
me figure that out you know and so it's
weird for me when people are like that's
the girl that we wanted you to be and
I'm like that girl was so insecure and
had so confused and like trying her best
but this girl who may not look the way I
like who I am I feel good I'm fine do
you feel sexy now yeah you should yeah I
mean not every day but like you know in
I have my moments and you know there's
definitely times where I look in the
mirror and I'm like oh dear God what is
happen oh my God those and then there's
other times where I'm like like oh she
got it it's fine um but but I but they
they pick this age and I love that
Taylor Swift said it because I was like
she's right like they do they they find
this little pocket of time and they hold
you there um and I think is a society or
haters or you know whatever the small
group of people are out there I think we
have to I think we have to do better I
think we have to be kinder to people and
I think we have to allow people to
change and grow
and and look different and just wish
them well yeah it's hard I think that's
why Ryan's here you can only hear him
you probably can't see him but hi Ryan
how you doing Ryan Jennifer Love wants
to
say but today I walked in I go should
don't wear this he goes you look like
you always do like you don't really give
a [__] but I'm like well I just I figure
if I don't try and I'm a guy it's way
different it's way different it's
obviously mean to guys too it is but
like you know people are like oh he
wears a T-shirt and he like you know
just wears sweats and just doesn't you
know is a dude and then whenever I do
dress up or something it's like hey and
I'd rather see that than to always be
like ah but he's always and then they
notice my aging more if I'm always
dressing up that's I think where my mind
goes plus I'm incredibly lazy um but
look it is hard it's you know how many
times have we all sat go oh my gosh what
happened to them you know and it's like
it's terrible it's judgmental and it's
like you know I stopped myself I go you
know what that's not cool that's not
cool but a lot of time the plastic
surgery it just is so it's so much that
you you have it's not even being
judgmental it's just being you can't not
talk about the
obvious you know what I mean and you
know I what happens to with me is what
upsets me is that it starts at such an
early age now like people are getting
plastic surgery in their 20s 19 20 and
it's like you're going to develop more
and you're growing into yourself and
it's like this is your youth don't
change your youth unless you have an
abnormality and you want to change your
nose because it really doesn't give you
confidence or there's things out there I
get it but the you know seeing at such a
young age people doing this to
themselves and it's a lot of times it's
not good work or getting their lips
blown up and you know you have to be
really careful you have to be really
careful because it's just uh it's it's
hard but isn't it because of you know we
see the best of everybody and we and
there are so I mean the filters that are
out there are so crazy I mean my
daughter will play on filters like you
know she'll play with filters and she'll
be like whoa I look amazing and I'm like
no you don't you don't look like
yourself no Take that off you know but
then I'll use it but then I I'll use
that filter and then the world says that
I'm unrecognizable I'm like okay well
you know it's crazy you can't win you
just can't win but I do I do think that
um yeah aging is weird it's just weird
um and I think
that we just all have to be kinder to
the process but we also have to just let
people just let people age however they
age I know that some are never gonna AE
I mean look at Jennifer Lopez
yeah none of us can do that we can't do
that she's just she's just amazing and
gorgeous and like you
know everyone's gonna age how they age
and some people have better jeans some
people just have better jeans like you
know I wasn't born like your husband by
the way Brian he was born with good
jeans he's a hottie like I'm like oh my
God he's a hottie like he you great
jeans you look fantastic I would no I'm
not saying that because we're friends
I'm saying that you do look fantastic I
wouldn't I wouldn't bring it up if you
looked awful you
know little thing off this little thing
I'd like to go this is you know what you
don't even see that it's you know and
when you're on film you hope you see it
on camera when I cry on on 911 all you
see is this little like by the way on
911 when you're the operator right
you're the operator the emergency
operator at this point with all your
lines can't you just put the lines in
the screen and not have to memorize them
I would yes yeah yeah you don't need to
do that because you're reading them as
they're they get printed out or right
well some yeah some of some of it's up
there because of the things and then
some of it's not because they change
they have to you know they they're
constantly like rewriting or they'll do
my part before they do the emergency or
they'll do the emergency before they do
my part so it's all kind of but yeah I
mean it's you know you're able to you
know kind of for the phone calls and
stuff like that it's actually quite
helpful because they will actually run
the phone call up there for you so that
you can you can react as if you would if
you were hearing it yeah I pulled the
Brando a few times I would have like
lines written in a book or I'd have I
have the prop guys I go Hey listen when
I'm reciting that Alexander the Great
thing make sure it's in this book right
here on this page at this height so it
looks like I'm reading it or it looks
like I'm you know Criminal Minds on
Criminal Minds um when I was pregnant in
real life I like literally my brain was
just gone like I just it's like a thing
when you're pregnant like you just don't
remember anything and so I would I would
write some of my lines like in the files
we'd be on the plane I'd be like oh
suspect is a and he's you know yeah it
was laughing I'd be like guys I have
there's like literally nothing happening
upstairs I'm sorry I worked with an
actor once who taped his lines for his
coverage on my forehead I've I actually
put my lines of for another actor's
coverage who was a guest star and I said
we always do this we didn't but I was
like we always do this I put him on
there and and he still [__] it up I
was like Jesus dude just read the
[__] line
it's too small mate it's too small I
can't read the lines on the sheet mate
would you like me to write them out well
screw us when we get older right and
we'll be like huh yeah like can you step
back further I think everybody should
have earwigs that's what I think I think
we should just I can't do no no tried
I've had to do those like when I'm
singing and stuff before and it drives
me insane I can no no but these are
really tiny and they fit in your ear
they we still to learn our lines that's
our job yeah for
you um is 91 one how many years have you
been doing this
now uh six five or six is it fun or do
it feel like it's just sort of like for
me after season four five it started to
like go okay this is redundant I'm doing
the same thing I know what I'm doing
here it's kind of or does it get because
you have a complicated you know
character and relationships and stuff
like that so is it something that you
truly enjoy still doing or you're like
you're ready to move on to the next
thing you know I do still enjoy doing it
I love the people
I've been very lucky to have this job um
it's it sounds awful because it it was
so much work but like my character
started off so in so much turmoil and so
much drama and so much trouble and
everything that it was so fun to play
but then the audience really wanted her
to get like happy and kind of normalized
again and that part is hard for me
because I really liked I really liked
playing I really it was the one of the
first times that I didn't have to just
play like the Happy sweet nice girl you
know what I mean and so I I miss I miss
Maddie's turmoil a little bit which
sounds awful to say because you should
want for you know people to be happy and
and joyful um but I do miss her turmoil
a little bit so um it's it's still an
amazing job that I love doing but I do
miss I do miss that so I'm I'm always
like can we
we have something get messed up again
like she screw up another 911 call and
it'd be her fault and then she has to
report to the you know yeah something I
told her I told her to get the gun and
then she shot herself it was it was my
mistake I don't know what I was thinking
and then you go into alcoholism and have
to go to AA and you're really upset
about this you visit the mom how I love
how her issues always come up and and we
have done like last season was sort of
an issue less season for her um and so
I'm hoping that in this next one maybe
we can you know they can come back again
just just a little every now and then
because it's fun for me they're hard
days when I have to do all that but I
secretly love it um so I think that that
would be that would be fun and then I
feel like I'm I feel like I'm ready for
like my Christmas movie
era wait a minute you want to start
doing
Hallmark I mean I don't like lifetime
like I don't know I just have never and
you love Christmas
I've never done the Christmas thing I
have so many friends that have done
those and they love them I want to do it
ER Durant Amanda clut like like they
love doing them and it's fun and you
could write your own if you want and you
could produce and you could do all that
you you know so I'm ready to step into
like my Christmas movie era too and I
feel like some of my friends are like no
that's what happens when you're in your
40s and you go do Christmas movies and
I'm like but I am in my 40s and I want
to do christas Smo so I'm kind of
looking forward to doing something like
that maybe after 911 to kind of you know
be like emergencies and then Joy well
why can't maybe think about like if you
do a Christmas story maybe I'm your
alcoholic brother why don't you come
direct to why don't you come direct to
Christmas movie I I would do that if you
were in it I would do we'd have a blast
that would be fun I would do that I
would do it if it was fun and it was
like you know just for would would you
be like the the guy in a Christmas movie
I'd like to be the alcoholic brother
that kind of gets a [__] gets a [__]
together at the end that's not done a
lot no I'm kidding I could
be how about the guy that you don't
think she's gonna end up with like the
guy that the delivery guy I'm delivering
Amazon time I'm delivering yeah I'm
delivering Amazon packages all the time
and I'm just like hey great and you're
like hey would you mind putting that out
there BL you know I'll take care of that
for you I'll do that hey you look really
nice today Mrs uh Johnson and uh you
know all of a sudden you're like he's
really nice and he's cute but he's the
delivery guy I I don't know if I can and
then I say you know I'm actually a
millionaire I just do this for fun we
should hang out I'm reconsidering I'm
reconsidering my offers it's a bad idea
I've really blown it I'm not sure I'm
not sure have you ever seen a Christmas
movie uh Christmas
Story um Christmas
vacation I okay I haven't seen any
lifetimes yeah you got to you got to
watch like the like you know send me one
send me one that you think is good you
should watch Amanda's it's great oh I
did see some of that I liked it you did
a really good job fit for Christmas yeah
she's great that's right I did see that
that was wrot it who's amazing and also
my friend so proud OFA Amanda's
fantastic wait didn't you introduce me
to her yes yes you did she's my neighbor
we become good friends yeah you're just
uh yeah you know how I didn't you to
become friends but that's okay whatever
do you do you still do you bastard do
you still get anxiety do you still get
depressed do you still go to go to
therapy yes yes yes and
yes yeah um I do still get anxiety I
will say the affirmations have been
helping a little bit um and I'm gonna
give you oh I have to tell you this
because you will love this and you will
use it you're like one of the few people
that I know that will actually use it um
this amazing woman that I know um Carol
she's like a a healer and just she's
just amazing but she's she's also been
one of my like really close friends for
20 plus years and um she's taught me
this new thing L that when anxiety or
fear comes up she will just text me and
say sit with me under the tree of No
Doubt and the tree of no
doubt it's just it's all goodness like
every Branch carries possib the tree of
No Doubt Joy love whatever it is in your
mind um everything works out in your
favor the universe always provides under
the tree of Doubt um text me that text
me that it's yeah I will I will and it's
really beautiful and you can use it any
time that you want and so I've been
trying to do that lately like if
something Creeps in I don't wait for it
to kind of build or you know I don't
kind of force myself to be like let's
sit in this and and see where this is
I'm just like I'm not I don't want to be
in that space right now and so I'll
either text her back and say hey meet me
under the tree of No Doubt or I'll just
in my mind picture this like whatever
this tree is for me and I'll just sit
there for a second with my breath and
good thoughts and like just kind of
letting go of the stuff that was
starting to sort of come up and I feel
so much better so I am gifting you the
tree of no doubt you can sit with me
there anytime you want and I can text
you that I'm doing that you can text me
and say sit with in the under the tree
of No Doubt and I will I will sit with
you it reminds me of that song um
remember the movie Over the Top with
Stallone yes and that song Meet Me
Halfway yeah across the sky but sit with
me under the tree of doubt that's what
I'm thinking I'm gonna do it you should
write aong sit with me under this tree
of Doubt that'd be a good title No Doubt
of no of no doubt that's what I meant
but I would call it the tree of
undoubt oh I like that that the tree of
undoubt I kind of like that um if you
could do any of the movies or shows that
have passed that you've done you see
these reunions you see all these people
getting together for another episode I
think Seinfeld's doing another episode I
know yeah so it's crazy would you do
revisit Party of
Five no I would do Ghost Whisper you
would you'd go back to Ghost Whisper you
love that show and that lasted what
eight years I loved it yeah it was it
was one of my favorite jobs Melinda
Gordon hands down one of my favorite
characters I've ever played if not my
favorite today um and yeah I would love
to do it but nothing else what about I
Know What You Did Last Summer would you
make an appearance if they did a third
one 100% you would yeah yeah yeah you
love those movies love making those
movies I mean but talk about like people
being like well she doesn't look 18
anymore um but I would do it Campbell
she's doing a new scream and they're all
older is she's amazing she looks amazing
I just hung out with her couple of weeks
ago for the first time and she didn't
know that I was a big fan and uh some of
the guys some scream I'm friends with
like ski uh and Matt they uh introduced
me to her and I sat next to her at you
know we were at this restaurant we just
all hung out and she was the funniest
sweetest like just oneliner cool do you
know her
I do just for I mean I was really young
when we did Party of Five but um but
yeah I always enjoyed like spending time
with her and she was just she's just a
cool person um she was always really
cool and always very funny she thought
that I was a major dork I think because
I was a kid but um but yeah we she was
just great wait how many years older is
she than you uh not that she's probably
my age she's probably 50 but because I I
started that show when I was 15 so like
an 18-year-old was like older to me you
know what I mean right and you weren't
even supposed to be you weren't even a
regular until season two you did it like
a nine episode Arc yeah I was just
supposed to be on for Nine episodes and
then it kind of kept going yeah was it a
great time in your life oh loved it
loved it Scott
Wolf the dreamiest I mean I got to be
Scott Wolf's girlfriend on TV I me as a
as a real life teenager I got to pretend
that guy was my boy was he not the
nicest sweetest raised so well I to this
day
I feel the the joy and and the kindness
just coming out in his texts oh he's
he's yeah the kindest sweetest he yeah
we just had we just had a blast it was
it was so fun do you you know I I want
to ask you this and then we'll get into
the shitalking
questions uh that are fun but I always
loved hearing you sing I always loved
you know I always joke about it but I
love that song bare naked and I loved a
lot of your other songs and I always
thought you such a wonderful Voice have
you ever thought of making a new album
just for you just something that cuz you
love music or is it something that H I
don't really want to do it anymore um I
do think about it all the time um yeah I
do think about all the time I don't I
don't know how to do it like just for me
you know what I mean like I I would have
to maybe you could tell me how to do
that like to just write songs and like
put them out and you know whatever um
but uh yeah I I would love to do that at
some point I just haven't I just haven't
done it what if I wrote a really good
song a little duet with us yeah on my
album would you would you consider it
100% because I wrote a song but I didn't
think of you because I didn't think
you'd do it and you were busy and your
kids oh because you didn't think of me
well well I would have but it's called
the we're losing the connections oh the
connection's gone no I just was like she
doesn't want to do this but like you
know I I'll write something if you end
up wanting to do it or not but and you
could always write it with me but I
wrote a song called the letter on my
last album or the second to last album
on sunspin and it's a little duet and
it's a little country-ish and it's
really cool I love it's one of my
favorite songs but my friend Emma
recorded with me and I'm like you would
have been great but I I would love to do
some kind of like little duet with I
would love to do that always think of me
yeah I would love to do that I will
think of you thank you remember that
song You'll Think of Me who is that
Keith Urban oh oh Keith urb I Love Keith
Urban wait do you like country music
country guy yeah that's awesome I like
Old Country Eddie Rabbit Ronnie Milsap
Alabama uh I'm starting to like the uh
the uh Jud
sisters yes some of their stuff I'm like
wow they're actually really good I never
really listened to them little Kenny
roggers little dolly a little who
doesn't like Kenny Rogers and Dolly
little the best yeah the best what's
your favorite band of all time my
favorite band of all time
Journey what's your favorite song from
Journey I mean probably Don't Stop
Believing you don't like cender my
love no I love all of them I love all of
them but if I had to pick a favorite
like
go what what's the one song you'd sing
besides what's the one0 song go-to for
karaoke for
you I don't know if it's 80s but um what
is the oh my gosh now I'm blanking on
the song Don't say Harry Styles is it it
was missing you John weight yes was that
80s I ain't missing you at all that's my
jam obsess do you know who she went out
we should remake that song as a do I
would do that and there's a song let's
do
that oh Telegraph tonight I am missing
you at all yes that could be that's a
hard yeah no it's not every time I think
of you I always catch my breath
and I hope it's good breath because I'm
a breath guy and I want
bre I love that song Yes wonder why you
left see you you can just hear it you
got to sing you got to sing again I'm
writing a song for us okay I am this has
been a joy Thanks for opening up about
your mom about Hollywood about life I'm
so glad you're taking care of yourself
you look great I love the gratitudes um
I'll meet you under the tree of
undoubt I can't wait and I will sit with
you promise you'll feel better sit with
me I need it and um I love you I can't
wait to hang out with your husband that
was weird I love you
too I love you huitt if you're even
listening to this huitt who calls you
huitt hey you know huitt or is it JH
what would it be love
huitt thank you love huitt thank you
love I want to thank you love love for
them do you remember love huitt sounds
like a guy who played bass in the 70s
now batting third baseman love huitt and
that here's the pitch on the way a base
hit by love huitt he's going to try for
two and he's out love
huitt at the bottom of all right there
we go the Lesser known Mets player yeah
Mets are terrible uh thank you for being
on the podcast we had a blast with you
and it means a lot that you came back
on maybe one day you'll come to the
house and do it in person huh what do
you think of that uh I want to thank
everyone for listening Ryan thanks for
being here um and this will Air Tuesday
MH I was excited to hear this episode
because I spent most of it looking after
your dog oh you did you're hoping it
came together and it was recording Jess
Bill and Joe were not available so I was
I was on dog Duty during this recording
oh I remember I remember they were
barking you had to let you had to let uh
I said Buffy Buffy you let Buffy out
yeah you let uh buddy no not that buddy
it's Charlie I remember my dog's name
that's how this day is going
uh thanks for listening uh big shout out
to my top tier patrons I'm about to read
their names off if you're a top tier you
also get your name shouted out every
episode and I adore you join patreon.com
inside of you and um I will send you a
message and thank you for the support
means a lot Nancy D Kristen and Leah see
I didn't say Leah and Kristen I said
Kristen and Leah this time Kristen gets
First Billing what do you think of that
Kristen lilisa Yukiko hi Yuko hi Jill e
and Brian H Brian H good to see you at
the depes mode night that was a blast
Nico P
hey big love to that little boy yours
big love to him I'm thinking about him I
hope he's feeling better
z uh Robert B Jason W Sophie M Sophie M
I just saw Sophie M Dream Weaver how are
you dream Rashi still around baby still
around Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal
F Janelle B Mike E Lon Supremo 999 more
San Diego M Chad W lean P hi lean MADD s
Belinda n Dave H you know Dave
Hall do you think Dave likes when I do
this when I shout out to Dave Hall
because I love him so much you should
ask him Dave send me a note you like
this Sheila G oh oh she you know I want
to be your only one go ahead Ryan Brad d
Ray h t with a t Tom n Talia M Betsy D
ran and C Cory K Dev Nexon Michelle a
Jeremy C Brandy D and Joey M that was
really sexy I was going for 947 the wave
Vibe
947 the
wave the last Uber I was in was
listening to that 94.7 right now shout
out to Eugene and Leo Cory Angela F Mel
s Christine s we've got Gloria eston
coming up after this Eric G Shane R
Andrew M good uh shout out to Amanda R
Kevin e Stephanie K uh hopefully those
people down in Sacramento are okay Joel
jam and J lean and J Luna R and Mike F
94.7 The
Wave Stone AG Brian L says he's really
sorry
and says he's sorry wants to try
anything to get back together baby uh
Jules M Kendall L Jessica B Kyle F
Marisol P Kaye J Brian a Ashley F Mar
and Louise L Romeo B Frank B and Jen T
Nikki L April R Randy s
jdw sounds like a lawyer jdw in
Associates it does oral P it's almost
like the toothbrush Oral B oral P Ginger
Insomniac Rachel D Melissa H Nick W
Stephanie and Evan Charlene a Don G
Jenny B
laurelai is not no longer here laurelai
gave up on the podcast I don't know what
to tell you sorry if you give up on a
podcast what else are you going to give
up on in your life we still we still
love you
anyway uh that's about it um that's all
I got guys I hope you had a great
holiday and uh from uh the Hollywood
Hills and Hollywood California I'm
Michael Rosen bom I am Ryan Taz I'm here
as well we love you and and Ryan say the
magic
words whoa be good to yourself
always be good to
yourself all right see you
[Music]
guys